with the surging levon aronian first of
all lev congratulations what a match
this was
he played the petra for the second time
and it felt like almost got a winning
position actually did get a winning
position but you did survive that end
game and after that it just felt like
you took over the match how did you live
uh this crazy intense match
yeah definitely that uh first game was
uh
you know
i i should have lost that game and then
i don't think it would be easy to come
back from it because
uh lanier is such a
solid player
and
once i got lucky there i think
it really that that was a swing and a
match
one of the trends of this match felt
like you taking risks in the opening but
focusing on the practicality of the time
control you are playing really fast
putting a lot of pressure on his time
even that benoni structure situation
that you had with the black pieces it
was lost for you then it was winning for
you then you finally managed to win that
game was that something that you came
into this match with this strategy
uh you can say that it's strategically
lost a position but
well your opponent has to prove it you
know there are weaknesses but there's
also a lot of counter play
and uh it's type of position hikaru
would play with black so i was kind of
inspired
you know he likes to put the pawn on g5
and you know
it does look ugly but there are always
some tricks with g4 so
i was hoping
because i thought that
for lanier after this
upsetting first game
and then the second
game that he was also defending
it would be kind of unpleasant to face
something that
is asking him to play
very precise very concrete play and then
he had this uh
opportunity to play bishop to h7 did you
spot this move
after bishop to a6 knight d6
uh
i've actually missed knight c4 yes
and now after knight takes the fight
bishop to h oh no i didn't see this move
at all
oh wow uh-huh
so
that is a problem yeah
he did not spot this move and he found
that brilliant knight to c3 forcing
resignation in this game and let's go to
the final game
the crazy final game because
well you got a completely winning
position yes out of the opening you are
cruising towards the victory in the
match and then something happened this
rook takes h2 came on the board no i saw
it
you did yeah yeah i said i saw the rook
sit so well i of course i can play uh
you know after queenie frequency four i
can play any move queen two yeah it's
easiest but i thought uh you know i will
calculate a little bit and just uh
you know i saw this rook c1 and i
thought all right you know there's no
way he has something more than a draw
and rook c8 of course came as a cold
shower yeah that's now
i don't know
it's definitely very
not so friendly
but lavonne i mean
this match has been about uh
perseverance and
and holding if you're holding difficult
difficult positions and you did it once
more
you saw the fortress that you achieved
in the game from afar i think there was
a couple of moments that he could have
maybe forced the win of an exchange
which would get to the draw but uh
i think
more or less this position that that he
achieved what
were you most afraid of or what what did
you not want to see him achieve from
this position as black if he gets his
knight on f5
you know then
kind of
this is this kind of feels uh like um
one of this uh
kurt's positions you know where black
has this pawn e7 and the king is
running around but he never commits with
e6 so it's kind of annoying no perpetual
checks yeah right
and the knight gets to f5
that was the one thing you wanted oh i
thought generally i should be drawing
this
i mean i wasn't
really too afraid but it's a practical
game yeah and
i'm uh
notoriously famous for leaving my pieces
on pray
[Laughter]
that's why when i had a chance to get
rid of one rook
you know
as my friend boris geffen says you know
the more you exchange the less you will
blunder so deep you exchange the rook
for the night and uh
now you can only blunder one rook and
not the second i got to ask you about
the upcoming finals it's number one
versus number two uh
you have a long long history with fabi
uh but he did knock you out of the
the uh
hold on now i can't even remember the
tournament never mind
you have a long history tell us what
you're looking forward to about this
finals match
i'm a survivor
i go this far so i just want to you know
kind of enjoy it and see
if
you know this uh training that i've got
with my opponents and
especially
me kind of
fighting till the end if it's if it will
be useful tomorrow i'm wonderful
alejandro
no absolutely congratulations what an
impressive display of nerves tell us how
do you manage not to blunder into a
queen check when you have seconds on the
clock
i think it's i don't know it's kind of a
natural thing i do blunder a lot but
then
sometimes i don't so this is kind of a
roulette you know i understand my
opponents must be very upset
the ball is bouncing around yeah
they're looking at me blundering
continuously and then suddenly in one
game i don't so
yeah that's very upsetting
one final question uh lev i see you're
sporting some impeccable green shoes
with uh some avocado socks is that it
i guess lime green it's a dark green and
and there you have it guys maybe we can
zoom on the avocado right now it looks
black but it genuinely is a dark green
with the matching socks who's who's
helping you with the fashion
ani of course and she knows that uh
you know she's uh
when she's negotiating with me
she knows that whatever crazy idea she
gets is going to pass you know that she
knows that i like to just you know wear
anything for fun right try things out
for her
because she likes fashion a lot it's a
lot of fun
lev congratulations once again and we'll
see you tomorrow thank you our
congratulations as well yeah looking
forward to that match fabiano carrana
versus